he's going to be talking about
designing and deploying online
experiments with plan out he's a
researcher and a senior member of the
facebook data science team he's been
conducting field experiments at facebook
over three years focusing on
diffusion of information behaviors and
networks he also develops tools and
methods for online experiments including
plan out an open source toolkit for
designing field experiments
and he holds a phd in information from
university of michigan and a bs in
mathematics from u of i
thank you
thanks uh i'm eitan bakshi i'm a
researcher on the data science team or
i guess it's now called the core data
science team at facebook
uh some of the tutorial is going to be
just me talking at you
via a bunch of slides but there'll be
some portion that can be
interactive so if you just follow this
link
it'll take you to this webpage
where uh we suggest that you install
ipython and plan out so you just do
sudo easy install plan out and then you
can check out
plano so i'm going to go into my
terminal
and do a git clone
and we'll continue with the tutorial
so to consult a statistician after an
experiment
has been finished is often merely to ask
him to conduct a porsche
mortem examination he can say what the
experiment died of
so oftentimes when people run
experiments or
a b tests uh
it seems very straightforward but
oftentimes it isn't there could be all
kinds of errors in randomization and
analysis
uh and it can be really dangerous to
build your own tools in fact even if you
have pretty good internal tools it can
be easy to make errors in your analysis
and so what i'm going to be talking
about is a package that we developed
that makes it easy and foolproof to run
experiments
so the plan out package is a
python-based framework for designing and
implementing experiments
and it promotes good statistical
practice and it mimics many of the key
aspects of facebook's internal facebook
experimentation stack so the main
component is plan
out which is this kind of language or
system for
assigning units to randomized
parameterizations and then a logging
system
and a management system and all of these
are just
kind of generically called plan out uh
but as i talk i'll be
referring to plan out to to mean more
specifically
uh this kind of assignment system
and so the outline for today is i'm
going to talk about motivation
uh running why run experiments
uh what kind of experiments do we run on
the core data science team why do i
think this is exciting
and then i'll talk about the ideas
behind plan out
uh and then dive into the tutorial where
we'll be
going through some ipython notebooks
so why run experiments well
the the internet industry experiments
are are very common we often refer to
them as a b
tests they're they're most commonly used
to deploy
you know two ready-built versions of a
website
uh so you know here's an example of the
facebook news feed in 2011
and uh you know through some gradual or
some drastic redesigns we now have
the facebook news feed as it looks on
the right hand side
but rather than rolling out just
completely different versions
we might use experiments to just explore
design space
so we might try to uh
manipulate these little icons in the
upper
left-hand corner to get users to use
certain features
or to maintain a closer connection with
their friends of iron messages
or we might modify the search engine in
some ways
uh or you know add some apps or promote
pages
etc in the the left-hand column maybe
we'll change
uh particular story units
so in this way experiments aren't just
for
evaluating two completely built
alternatives but to try to understand
uh kind of what are possible changes
small changes that we can make to the
website that can have
impacts on on user behavior
we can also use experiments to
understand trade-offs
in our design space so here's an example
of an experiment that we ran with
facebook
offers which is a kind of way of
distributing coupons via facebook
and the default behavior of coupons
was as soon as you redeemed a coupon
it would kind of share that information
with all your friends much like
liking a page automatically shares this
and what we wanted to know is what is
the effect of doing this we're
potentially
exposing users to users friends to
information that might be
a little bit less relevant so what
happens if we instead add a share button
so this is a simple experiment that has
a rather complex analysis
and gets it a very deep question about
pure effects and networks right
how are your interests correlated with
your friends interests and
how does sharing have certain downstream
consequences as to the relevance of
users
behaviors we can also use experiments to
attribute outcomes to causes
so we have non-social ads which don't
feature friends in social ads which
embed social cues
alongside ads so here's an example of
a non-social ad and a social ad
where we can see that my friend gina
likes the history channel
and perhaps somehow this persuades me to
like the page but it could also be
that because i have a friend who likes
that page they might be more similar to
me
and so as a result i might be more
likely to click the page so it doesn't
really tell us anything
about whether social ads cause
users to click on the ads more or like
more pages but it tells us
uh something about the kind of
correlation between people's interests
and social networks
so we could instil instead run a
randomized experiment
where we show uh either zero friends
given that you have one liking friend or
one friend
given that you have one liking friend
and we could implement a lot of these
very complex experiments
that show any number of social cues with
just a couple lines of plan out code
so those are some examples of
experiments that we run
that give us kind of deeper behavioral
insights uh
into our ecosystem rather than just
testing two alternatives
and so far these experiments seem pretty
easy right i'm we're just adding or
removing a button
changing light gray text on a white
background but experiments can be really
hard
there are all kinds of organizational
problems that can occur you have
multiple teams running multiple
experiments you have a single team
member
running multiple experiments how do you
make sure those experiments don't
collide in some way
or that your analysis interferes with
somebody else's analysis
if you need to change something how
should you analyze these experiments
that's not entirely obvious even to the
statistician this isn't
really clear
furthermore experimentation can be a
mess you can have experimental logic
that's scattered across your entire code
base
and it's really difficult to keep track
of exactly what your experiment is
what the manipulation is and then as a
result if you make any kind of change to
your code base
it could potentially break your
experiment and this is really
problematic as you start to scale up
your company
and you have many engineers working on
your product
it also makes it difficult for analysts
who might not necessarily be software
engineers to understand the details of
your experiment
which could be really dangerous
furthermore because your your code is is
tied into the application logic it also
makes it difficult to run
experiments on multiple platforms so if
you have
an android device and an ios device and
a server
and you kind of want the the same
experimental code to be executed on
different versions
of your platform uh how can you make
that possible
and so the solution that we came up with
is this
uh kind of domain specific language and
interpreter called
planout which performs uh random
assignments
and so in the planout universe uh
you don't assign users to groups to test
groups it's not
user a belongs in group user x belongs
in group a or group b it's there's a
particular parameter
that controls the website like the width
of the news feed or the width of an
image
or some font size or how much padding we
have
and that's some constant and that can be
manipulated in some way
through random assignment and so we've
moved in this into this world from
test groups to parameterizations of
user experiences and so plano scripts
are high level descriptions of
randomized parameterizations
and so the plan out idea is that user
experiences are parameterized
by experimental assignments and plano
scripts describe
an assignment procedure so it's a very
concise definition
of how your experiment works and
an experiment is a plan out script plus
a population
in parallel and follow-on experiments
are essentially managed in some way and
and treated separately from one another
and so here is a sample plan out script
in the plano domain specific language
and what what this one script does is it
chooses a button
color with uniform probability and
independently
chooses button text with uniform
probability so this
definition generates a two by two
factorial design
now this script then gets compiled into
json and we have this serialized
definition that could be run on multiple
platforms
shipped across the network stored in a
database etc
the serialized code can also be executed
on
in multiple languages so i originally
implemented
uh planout and php and maintained a
parallel
version in python because i really
wanted to keep it portable
i guess one day i woke up and planned
out was written
in hack which is is pretty cool and
you could also imagine porting it to
other platforms as well
you can also generate serialized planet
code via gui so here's an example of a
gui we use
at facebook and we'll be talking about
how you might build kind of open source
versions of this in our tutorial
uh and then our our toolkit also
allows you to express plan out in a
pythonic way so here's an example of an
experiment definition
that implements very similar
functionality so this is the entire
experiment and then you're good to go
with logging
so it's it's this easy
yeah and feel free to ask questions at
any point in time
how do people feel about this font size
oh go ahead
i have a question sort of going back to
you what you said about compiling it
to json and then distributing across and
whatnot is that
uh specific to sort of the web
development stack
here at facebook um the way you chose
that approach
um the the purpose for that is that we
wanted to be able to
have centrally managed experiment
definitions
that could be constructed via graphical
interfaces
or just looked at set uh separately from
analysts
or just so that people designing
experiments don't even have to think
about how it's implemented in php
and so that kind of separation from the
application logic and the code
is is one of the main motivations i
guess this is a related uh
subject have you guys looked at other
frameworks i'm assuming you have
uh before you built plan out like vanity
and why did you choose not to use them
um i actually don't know what vanity is
uh
but i would be happy to talk to you
about it later i mean we
we have our own system that this plugs
into and we have a very large stack that
we work with
uh and i think eventually you'll you'll
see uh what kinds of experiments planout
is capable of expressing
and i i doubt that uh any other
framework that other people have built
can support the kind of experiments we
want to run
not uh yeah okay so
we we've got a plan out here that's
checked out
if we go to the contrib directory uh
and the tutorial directory we'll see a
bunch of python notebooks
we can launch the notebook
by typing in ipython notebook is this is
probably way too small for people
do folks want me to make the font bigger
yes
if i can see where the order is
okay so i i just basically copied and
pasted
uh this command that is both on this
wiki
and um and they read me and
in the both locally and externally
so here's the getting started notebook
toggle this stuff
so the first thing is this font size
okay for people cool
yeah the screen setup here is great so
most of your plano experiments will
import these
random operators which help you do the
random assignment
and then as you're starting out you're
going to be using this simple experiment
class
so this includes a bunch of built-in
stuff for doing logging
and then to for demonstration purposes
we're also going to use pandas
so we execute this so this is our first
experiment
this is going to be an experiment that
runs on a new user signup form
and what we'd like to do is assign
individual cookies
to different button colors and button
texts and here it's just a two by two
factorial
very similar to the other setup and so
to create a plan out experiment
using the the basic plan out framework
you define a class that inherits from
simple experiment
and then you define an assign method
and it has one required argument
which is params which is this kind of
helper object for doing random
assignment
and then some set of input units
so here it's cookie id it could be user
id you could also pass in
cookie id day or something if you wanted
to also do random assignment on the day
of the week
the next line actually performs one of
the random assignments and the way that
we do this
is we say set attributes of this params
object
so here we have an attribute which we're
going to call button color
and we set it to this object called
uniform choice
which picks among two choices with
uniform probability
using the input the cookie id
as the unit and what planout does
underneath the hood is it does a bunch
of hashing
so it says okay i'm setting an attribute
of params and this this thing i'm
setting it to
is a random operator so i'm going to
execute that random operator
and i'm going to use the name of the
variable that i'm setting
and the unit and the name of the
experiment
and combine them together and then do a
sha-1
hash in order to assign that set of
variables to a randomized condition
and this ensures that you get kind of a
good random assignment and that your
assignments are independent of one
another
and so here we're we're setting two
different factors
and the way that we use this is we
create instances of this class
to get an assignment so here we have the
cookie id is four
so we execute this this basically gets a
reference to the experiment
once we request a parameter
we actually get the value so here the
button text to sign me up
so it's the second choice if we were to
change these
the the randomizations would change
also underneath the hood there there's a
bunch of logging that's occurring
so if i go to my plan out directory
there's a bunch of log data that's
automatically being produced
that i'll be discussing in a couple
minutes
we could see a couple of randomizations
for different cookie ids
and if we're kind of skeptical that this
stuff works correctly
we can just simulate a bunch of user ids
what happens when we put a bunch of
sequential user ids through
our random assignment system
we can generate this data frame so this
is one way of getting a data frame of
random assignments
and then just tabulate stuff and we can
see that they're
kind of approximately uh distributed
one quarter each and like we could even
make this number bigger
and the plan out framework includes a
bunch of unit tests
that actually do legit statistical tests
to make sure all the random assignment
operators work correctly
we can also do unequal probability
assignment
so in this case we have a second factor
which is chosen
with a probability of 0.8 for join now
and 0.2 for sign me up so this could be
like any kind of arbitrary
integer floating point value
and then we see that when we run this
things show up in the expected
proportions
are there any questions so far
sorry i can't hear you we get
exactly the same size
yep if you run this on your machine it
should be identical
because plan out is deterministic
and that's that's the whole point you
don't have to store uh
kind of what you've randomly assigned
users to in some database and then go
look it up
because you know for the given uh
experiment definition and the given
input units exactly what they're going
to be hashed into
so everything is completely
deterministic and platform independent
uh one advantage
of this setup is that since it just uses
sha-1 and really simple hashing it's imp
easy to implement in other languages
whereas if we were to use
some random number generator we would
have to like find ports of that same
random number generator
on different platforms and um that could
get hairy
so here's another example of an
experiment so google is famous for
running this
51 different shades of blue experiment
for their
uh link colors
and if we wanted to implement this
experiment um
you know pre-plan out maybe this would
take an intern like a week to do
to code up each of these uh 41
conditions
actually hopefully they're a lot faster
than that
we can instead write this really simple
plan out script where we generate some
random integer value which is going to
be our blue value
between 215 and 255
and that's going to be deterministic
based on the user id
and then we can just kind of insert this
into
a hexadecimal string
i guess this should be link color
but oh well and you can see that when
you do
get params we see the button color
and the blue value
and we can run this for a whole bunch of
users
it's computing
and now if we look at histogram of all
the values you can see that it's
approximately
uniform and again all of this stuff is
unit tested
we could also do more complex
experiments that involve
assigning multiple units simultaneously
so let's say that we wanted to do it
within subjects design
where we are making a change to our our
ranking
a search range ranking algorithm and
instead of
assigning whole users to experimental
conditions
which might have problems with
statistical power if you think that
you know each individual user has
some individual level random effect or
fixed effect
you can get better power by randomly
assigning particular user session pairs
to experimental conditions so you can do
this kind of within subjects comparison
and the way that we do that is instead
of passing in user id as the unit we
pass in
user session id so here our assign
method
just takes this additional argument
and instead of unit being a scalar it's
just this list
and we can see that as we mess around
with this
we'll get different random assignments
we can also have randomized assignments
depend on each other in some way
right so plan out isn't just useful for
doing factorial designs
so let's say that we had a team
that had a series of related models that
they were testing
let's say they added some kind of
features about what users friends are
doing into the ranking of search results
and we wanted to compare the control
condition which let's say is the current
model which we label v zero
against uh three different versions of
the model uh
two one two two one three and two one
four
and for each individual subject we
wanted to uh
compare that baseline v0
against one of these experimental
conditions
so what we could do is assign each user
id
to one of these different new models
and then for each individual user
session pair we can randomly choose
among these two
options
so there's kind of like hierarchical or
nested assignment
we can see for this user id they end up
either in
v0 or v212 if we were to change the user
id
so let's say 30 they're still assigned
to 2 1 2
31 they're assigned to v
0 or 2 1 4.
so what's going on underneath the hood i
kind of discussed this very briefly
earlier
but the idea is that we construct this
string which is the name of the
experiment
plus the parameter name plus the input
unit
so if you have an experiment that's
called random example one
and a variable that's called x and the
input unit let's say
the user id is four to do the uniform
choice so we might do something like
sha1 take a couple digits of shot one
and mod it by two and that's how we're
producing the random assignment
and so uh this middle component is the
parameter level salt
and so what it uses as the salt so the
salt is just like some modification
of input string or integer that you're
hashing on
in this case when we set params.x we're
using
x as the salt so if we were to take this
code and just say
salt equals x
it's not going to change the assignments
right before a
0a was 494
if we nuked this it'd still be 494.
now if we change salt of x
of x to be x1
and not insert an extra comma we would
see that that number changes
but it's completely deterministic each
time
now if we use the same salt
for two different variables
the assignments would be correlated so
let's say that we use the salt
x2 both for x and y
what do folks think is going to happen
when we do the crosstab
yeah so it's go these two variables are
then going to be perfectly confounded
and so uh we're only going to have two
unique values
right every time we pick 0 we're going
to pick a
and every time we pick one we're going
to pick b
so that's how parameter level salts work
there's also experimental assaults so
experiment salts are also
set automatically and that's based off
of the class name
so let's say that we had two experiments
with essentially
identical random assignment procedures
so in this case random example one and
random example two
since they use the same variable name
and are both doing uniform choice
of two objects just like an a and a b
test
for this parameter they should be
producing some kind of correlated
assignment if we don't do anything
special
but if we run this we find that the the
crosstabs are different
because it's not just using the variable
name
it's also using this
experiment to do the salting
now what we can do is manually set the
salt
so if i were to say uh if i were to
define the setup
function or method um
which gets run before the experiment
actually gets executed
and i said self.salt equals
this string
now these two things are going to be
perfectly correlated
because we're using the exact same
parameter names and the exact same salt
and essentially the same kind of
assignment
and you could imagine that in general
there are a lot of cases where you would
use the same variable name
you might use the variable name button
color and you might be doing an a b test
because in general 50 50 splits are
the best thing you can do in order to
increase statistical power
an additional note slash gotcha is
that uh the order of the units
that you give plan out matters
when you're passing in a list of units
so in these two cases the random
assignments are different
even though they're both using user url
pairs so it matters if it's a
user url pair versus a url user pair
and then we'll talk a little bit more
about how this fits into the management
infrastructure does anybody have any
questions about random assignments
i don't want to derail anything but is
there a 10 second answer to um
turning off the login in the notebook
when i'm
running this oh yeah i'm i have no idea
okay all right and that's fine thanks if
there are people who are like
really competent ipython users
uh it'd be great if somebody could
figure this out i i think that
like three or four
out of five three out of four or four
out of five
people who have tried this uh don't have
any issues
but i think there's some ipython
installations uh
where things are kind of worked
okay now on to logging
one question back there
so let's say you're using a uniform
distribution and
rather than putting in you know zero and
one as my options
uh do those need to be unique can i can
i put zero zero zero
one and does that get grouped together
or can i use that as kind of a point
yeah you can do
zero zero one and that is to treat those
as distinct categories or not
those are gonna be logged in the exact
same way
okay uh because if if you think about uh
the way that this is being integrated on
the front end or whatever system is
hooking into it
they're just requesting parameters from
the experiment and so
their plan out has no concept of group
there is no control group
versus treatment group or an a versus a
b it's just the parameter
so you know one get way of implementing
uh a weighted choice would be to just
insert the same
variable multiple times in the list
uh you could talk about what data
you're collecting from the experiment
yeah we'll we'll talk about i think
that'll be a little clearer
once we get to logging
okay so if folks want to open up their
terminals
and go to this pi data tutorial
directory
they're going to find a bunch of log
files
that have gotten poops out
automatically
and what we're going to do is
we're going to execute this logged
experiment
and we're going to look at some of the
log data that's produced by this
so by default it uses the experiment
name it uses the logger
module to output files to
log files with the same name as the
experiment so in this case the
experiment is logger experiment so we're
just going to tail-eff it
so this will give us the results as they
come in
actually when i clear my terminal
wow what is that
so here we have an experiment that's
kind of similar to the
the facebook composer where people can
post status updates and in this
experiment
we've got some parameter x which is
either what's on your mind or say
something
and that's assigned with uniform
probability and then we have this other
function that's essentially or operator
that's essentially a coin flip
and it's going to produce data and pump
it out to this log file
and so each time you
get an assignment for
this particular there we go
for a particular unit it's going to log
it right
so each time i do this there's going to
be a log
now if i were to just run this let's say
we have a different user id and we're
not requesting any parameters
no log is produced so this is called
exposure logging and it happens
automatically
and so the idea is that an individual is
exposed to a treatment
once you request a parameter that could
possibly affect their user
experience so if you're just saying like
get me an instance of this
this class and you're not doing anything
with it then
there's no reason to say that that user
was exposed to the treatments
and by only considering users who are
actually exposed to a treatment
you can substantially increase the
statistical power
of your experiment
and you can see that when when we do
this random assignment
and we request get multiple times
it doesn't produce any additional logs
and that's because the way we've set up
simple experiment
was that it only does an exposure log
once per
instance of the class and
in a production system what you would do
is probably implement something that
checks a memcache key
to see if you've exposure logged that
particular input for that experiment
and if you have you don't need to log
that data again because you know the
user has been exposed already
you can also do manual exposure logging
so here we have a log exposure method
and then you can
optionally put in
additional data so here we're recording
the endpoints
that produce the content
or it didn't actually the the end point
for which we're showing the status
update you can also have event logging
so let's say they actually post a status
update we can log the event
posted status update uh and we can log
some kind of metadata
like that it was a photo
and so there are two ways to think about
the logging
here's kind of a simplified picture of
how our experiment analysis pipeline
works
is we have exposure log data that's
joined against some metrics
that are automatically collected so
let's say how often
a user has logged in in the past however
many days or how many cons
how many uh pieces of content they've
produced in the past however many days
and that's joined on the exposure log
and then there's also an event log which
might be some particular conversion
instance
so let's say that i'm running an
experiment that has to do
with um
getting users new friends we might log
this particular event
and that would be in the event log or we
can just join all of our exposure logs
against this kind of routinely collected
data
and then that gets processed in some way
we do some automatic analysis and that's
available via
graphical interfaces
and so let's put all of this together
via a sample web application
how am i doing on time
okay cool so we've got the sample web
application
and let's say it's an experiment that
runs for a music store
and so users can uh view particular
albums
and they can listen to songs and
we're trying to test what would happen
if we were to sort songs within the
album by rating instead of track number
so this is our hypothetical experiment
and this is the code we're just
assigning this one
binary variable which is sort by rating
and that's going to be
one with a 20 chance
and that's being hashed on user album id
pairs
right and by hashing it on the pairs we
we don't necessarily
we won't necessarily affect particular
albums differentially
and we can also get greater precision
because this is a within subject's
design
now we're also going to define this
method called get price
which is how much the album costs let's
just say all albums are 199
and now we have some kind of rendering
web page so this
is something that exists on your uh
front-end service that renders the page
and what we do
is we retreat we retrieve the
experimental assignment
for the user album id pair and then we
log the exposure with the price
oftentimes it's not even necessary to
call log exposure
we get the parameter we might do
something that affects
how the content is rendered and then we
would generate the html and render the
template
for example so that's the the render web
page
code then after
users are presented with this this
interface
they could potentially purchase an item
and so we might have
some code that handles a purchase and
in this case we'll get the experimental
assignment
log the outcome and then do whatever
else like
let's say download the album onto the
user's computer
so this is the handler
now what we're going to do as part of
the simulation
is write this function that's simulate
user decision
and what we're doing here is just using
planout to get the hypothetical
experience of the user so this is not
something that like
would exist in your your hypothetical
code although it might exist
uh if you're an analyst and you're
trying to do a power analysis for your
experiment
sorry i might have missed it but did you
mention do you do
multinomial tests on the back end of
this like how do you
actually compute the significance of
your results
uh how does facebook compute confidence
in other words how does plan out
is just reports that counts that's all
it does uh plano doesn't do any
aggregation it just
logs raw data and
that's up to your kind of data analysis
infrastructure to you know either
fit whatever regression model or do the
bootstrap confidence intervals
typically we use a lot of bootstrap
confidence intervals
at facebook for evaluating the results
of our experiments
so yeah this simulates user behavior and
what we're doing here is turning off
exposure logging
because this isn't really like a legit
part of
uh the experiment flow and
we're simulating this user decision and
the idea is that if
they do not see the sorted version then
the probability of conversion is 0.1
and if they do see the sorted version
the probability of converting is 0.15
and so this is the generative bottle so
there's uh an absolute
treatment effect uh that's a 0.15
increase uh in the likelihood of
clicking on the the purchase button
so then we run the simulation this takes
a little while
it's done and so now we've recorded a
bunch of log data
so now if we were to go to our terminal
we can see that there's this music
experiment log
which is pretty large and has a bunch of
entries
and so we can load up this data uh each
line as
as you might recall is just this json
encoded blob
so we just use json.loads
for each line of the file
in a production setting this might be
writing your data
to scribe or a database
and so this is what each line looks like
once it's loaded in it's this kind of
nested dictionary
that shows the event type
whatever extra data all of your input
data
the name of your experiment what
parameters are being
assigned the salt that's being used in
case you change the salt midway through
which is kind of dangerous and a time
stamp
usually we want to deal with data in a
tabular format
so we can flatten this uh i stole this
piece of code
from stack overflow
and so we can take this kind of nested
data
and generate a flat table so this is
what the table looks like
the tableified data frame version
so we have this table and then what we
do is
we extract all of the exposures so
that's what this line does
and then we uniquify it right so we have
just a single row per user album
pair and that user album pair should
always be assigned to the same rating
so now if we want to know how many
individual pairs were assigned to each
condition
this would be the the cross tab for that
so you can see
that it's about eight to two
which is almost exactly
the proportion that we specified earlier
on
it's a probability of assignments of the
treatment with
probability of 0.2
and then we can extract the conversion
data
so here we extract the purchase events
then we
do a left outer join on the unique
exposures
and
one thing that's a little funky about
pandas that i've learned is that uh
price
or that missing entries are nan so
that's what this means so we don't have
a price
for these guys because of the the right
outer join
so then we have this boolean value
that's whether or not the user had
purchased for that particular
uh exposure and how much money we got
and then we could just uh do roll ups of
that so
let's say compute the mean uh purchase
rate
and the mean revenue and this purchase
rate
is exactly what we set up in our
generative model
and you might do something similar to
this in order to do power analysis
although personally i'd use r for my
power analysis
any questions on logging
does power analysis re refer to some
specific
thing or just just like power
calculations okay
it's not capital upper case power yeah
just
just power calculations uh oftentimes
i guess i i say power analysis because
uh i often use simulations because
you know it's not just a binomially
distributed data
and so we might want to use some real
outcome data that has a certain
distribution
and then we might have some covariates
which we know are correlated with the
outcome
and so we might do fit a regression
model
to the real data and kind of work with
some augmented data set
so yeah i mean you could potentially do
really complicated things
and potentially use planout to log data
and not do any treatment assignment
so that's another approach that you
could use for the kind of planning stage
of your experiment
yeah the earlier used like a uniform
uh variable and just set uniform choice
instead of the eight to two and here
using a binomial instead of 0.2
any difference uh you're saying weighted
choice versus binomial yeah
uh yeah i mean if if it's a uh
zero one variable then there's no
difference
if it's like a two element list but
weighted choice
could include any number of choices it
could be
a vector of like 30.
so the next thing i'm going to talk
about is the plan out interpreter
so at facebook when we use planout it
runs under a php interpreter
and we'll often specify our experiments
using this domain specific language
which looks a lot like javascript and
it's very similar to the plan out code
that you would write in
in pure python except the operators
start with a lowercase
and here's an example of a 2x2
factorial experiment we can compile our
code
by running this planout.js compiler
that you can find
in this compiler directory
i'm going to run the compiler from
ipython so it kind of
makes stuff a little easier and so
here's our our plan out code
and we can run this compile function
and we do this note that like to
actually execute this on your machine
you have to have node installed
so once we compile this this plan out
code we get this serialized json
and now we have the string object that
represents our experiment
which can be analyzed in various ways
automatically
by the software that's doing your data
analysis uh
or summarized to analysts in certain
ways
and this is actually the the code that
gets executed by the plan out
interpreter
and uh the way that we use the
interpreter object in planout
is by calling interpreter on the
serialized planout code
with some particular salt uh which will
be abstracted away as the experimental
level of salt
in a little bit and then a dictionary
that gets loaded up with all the input
data
so anything that you load up into this
dictionary exists in the plan out
execution environment and can be used
as variables over here
so in this experiment we're doing a
uniform
choice of the button text which is
purchase or buy
and then we give users a discount
with a 30 probability
and so we can see that we can run uh
this
serialized plan experiment definition
and produce different random assignments
now this code acts just like pure python
experiments it uses the same hashing
procedures
so let's say that we defined this
doppleganger simple experiment class
and we set the salt to be the same as
the salt here
and we use the exact same variable names
button text and has discount
in the same units
then the assignments we get are going to
be completely identical
because it's really using the same
objects underneath
we can also fit in this interpreter
class into
a simple experiment so we can extend the
simple experiment class
and override the assign method
to use interpreter and
run the interpreter and then basically
do a batch update of the params
another feature that i recommend using
is this checksum
so planet will automatically log a
checksum of your experiment definition
so that if somebody changes that your
experiment definition midway through
which
generally shouldn't happen uh
the analyst will be aware of that
and so now with this
we can just derive from this class
set the salt and then set the script to
be the serialized version
and it runs the experiment
and so now if we look at the log data
we can see that it's logged our
experiment
it logs the salt correctly and
we have this checksum and if we were to
just change our code in some way
like let's say instead of bios
by exclamation point and we were to look
at this log
now the checksum would change because
the experiment definition has changed
so there are also other ways does
anybody have any questions at this point
this might be beyond the scope of it but
i can see
changing your experiment and wanting to
track that but i guess there's also the
issue that
maybe some uh you think you're running
the same experiment but the underlying
code base has changed
is that just a completely
different set of tests you have to do
yeah i mean it's just really hairy when
that happens
and hopefully there'll be like some
announcement that a large
aspect of your site is changing um but
if
that change is really substantial it
should be hopefully obvious from your
data but yeah
obviously like you can't have the plan
out code or logging be aware of every
other change that happens to your site
um when i was following along it looked
like the
first in each group of five log
statements had a different checksum from
the other four
uh yeah i think that's because
i had
been messing with the definition
at various points
sorry i mean even if i put some spaces
in the log and run it again
right now without changing anything it
still looks like
user zero gets a different checksum
um
yeah i'm not really sure why that would
occur
we could chat about it later
so we can also generate planout scripts
oh is there one more question yep
yeah so my question is if we want to use
planar in other language
we just need to implement use that
language to implement this interpreter
yep yeah exactly yeah and it's pretty
easy to import the interpreter if you
look at the
the code the interpreter itself is super
short
so the the serialized code could also be
generated uh
algorithmically so let's say that you
have a user interface
on the front end that generates
dictionaries
that look like the name of the factor
whose keys are lists of the effector
levels
we can generate these scripts using a
function like this
and so you could just add additional key
value pairs
and it generates the experiment
definition
so this is another advantage of using
this crazy
experiment serialization is that you can
allow people to create experiments
without actually having to code anything
and then if you wanted to use this you
could write
little things to to generate these
scripts so all of this
will uh work with the plan out framework
so
you know here we're calling the
experiment my generated experiment
let's say that we change the experiment
name
just to my generated we would see that
it produced different experiments
with different log files
so that's how the planout interpreter
works
so the next thing we're going to talk
about is managing experiments
and so to do this we have this concept
of a namespace
and the idea behind a namespace is that
it's a parameter value store
and so you request values for parameters
and you have some back-end system that
says okay
what is the value of this parameter and
that might be some constant that's
floating around somewhere or it might be
something that's determined by an
experiment
and so this namespace manager takes care
of that and says
okay i have user id20
uh i'm requesting let's say the button
color
we're going to take that input user id
we're going to hash it to a certain
segment number
segment numbers are associated with
experiments
and then it says aha user id 20
is mapped to experiment number two and
then we're going to run the plan out
script for
experiment number two
and if the the input unit belongs to an
experiment
we do the logging and we return the
values
if it doesn't belong to an experiment we
don't necessarily do any logging because
the user isn't actually an experiment
and one thing to note about the way this
system works is we're not
mapping whole segments uh which do not
change over the over time
uh to particular experimental groups and
this
uh reduces carryover effects so this is
called uh local hashing
uh if you're familiar with any of the
the papers on
online experimentation
so how do namespaces work in practice
here's an example of kind of one
timeline for an experiment
that we launched where we had week one
and we launched an ex initial plan out
script to
a small uh number of segments
of users actually in this case they were
advertisers
and we ran the experiment for a short
period of time to make sure
nothing was totally borked and it seemed
like our revenue was okay
and so we increased the size of the
experiment and
uh in week two we launched this new
experiment with even more segments
then we decided some of these conditions
don't really work well it doesn't really
tell us
information about trade-offs that we're
trying to explore with the experiment
so we changed the number of experimental
conditions
added a few more conditions and so now
this is an entirely different plan out
script
and then we launched it to many users
and analyzed that over a long period of
time
and then eventually made a launch
decision
yeah a segment is just a partitioning of
the primary so the question was what do
i mean by segments
a segment is just a partitioning of the
primary units so if you're primarily
experimenting with users
uh users would belong to segments and so
you have some number of segments let's
say 10
000 and each of those segments is
randomly assigned
to an experiment and once that's
assigned to the experiment
there's additional random assignment
that occurs within that experiment
so once we go through the code example
hopefully it'll be a little bit
clearer how this works i know it's a
little abstract
so we have this class called simple
namespace
that we'll be using and then also
another class called default experiment
which is a lot like simple experiment
but it doesn't do any logging
and also has some functionality for just
storing dictionaries of values
so in general
namespaces represent a set of related
parameters
so things that have to do with uh all of
them
are like the ranking model for search or
all of them have to do
with the display of product results in
your search feed
or have to do with things that relate to
pricing
of certain goods and all of those
experiments are necessarily mutually
exclusive so you don't have to use a
namespace to manage experiments
that aren't actually modifying the same
variable that's used
in your code right
in general you should never modify an
already running experiment
you should instead launch new
experiments through namespaces
and experiments should be analyzed
separately
unless you really know what you're doing
and are using statistical procedures
that are designed to pool across related
experiments
so let's say that we have multiple
versions of an experiment
in this case we have
an experiment that has to do with a
banner that
is at the top of the user screen and the
first experiment it
says hello there or welcome uh
second version it says hello there
welcome with different probabilities
so same parameters different assignment
probabilities
third version uh it says
completely different things so these are
three versions of an experiment
they're all setting the same related
parameter which is the banner
and then we have this concept of a
default experiment so if the user
doesn't
belong to any experiment what is the
parameter
that we're going to return if it's
requested so in this case it's just
a generic generic greetings is the text
now here's how we define namespaces with
button namespace
uh this simple namespace is really just
a code example
that i'm providing for people to
understand how namespaces work
in general you would set up namespaces
through some kind of graphical user
interface that's available to engineers
on your website and stored via database
so for this particular class what we
have to do is specify the name
of your namespace which gets used to
salt
your hashing procedures you have to
specify a primary unit
so this is the unit that gets used uh to
assign inputs to segments
so you could potentially have an
experiment in a namespace
that operates off of user
segment pairs but it would partition it
initially by the user id
and then you specify some number of
segments so for the demonstration
version
i'm saying 100 in a production
environment you would want to use
something like 10 000 segments or 100
000 segments
and then when users are setting up the
experiments uh
they shouldn't really be aware of the
fact that like users or experiments are
allocated in terms
of segment numbers but in terms of
percentages
and then you can specify a default
experiment class so if a user
or an input does not belong to an
experiment this value is instead of
returned
and then there's this kind of stub
function which kind of
simulates what would happen if we were
to add or remove
experiments from the namespace again
this is something that would be done
via a database or a graphical user
interface in a production environment
so what was what we're saying here is
that we've got
three different experiments the first
two experiments
use the same uh planout script or
assignment procedure
and the first one has 30 segments the
second one has 10 segments
and the last one has 40 segments
and they all have different experiment
names so if we try this out with a few
users
here we see hello there
generic greetings
etc we could run this for a bunch of
input units
you can see that these are are clearly
in some cases coming from the default
experiment in other cases they're coming
from
v1 and other cases they're coming from
v2
and so what's going on underneath the
hood well we're giving it
let's say we give it user id 2
user id 2 belongs to segment number 2029
and if we look at the the segment
allocations
we can see how each segment number is
mapped to a particular
experiment name and here you see that 29
doesn't exist here
so this particular segment will not be
assigned to an experiment and instead
uses the default value store
and so when we do this this is going to
return
null and so we see that
the individual unit is not allocated to
the experiment
so if we were to try this with a
different user id you know
sometimes it'll i guess most segments
are not actually allocated to
conditions
but we can see that the number of
segments that we have
or experiments that are running do
correspond to the number of segments
that were
initially allocated
okay well that concludes
uh the tutorial for the most part
um again i would highly suggest using
namespaces if you're running
multiple experiments and to centrally
manage your experiments
and to analyze your experiments with
care if you want to somehow pool across
experiments or
run follow-on experiments
so just to recap uh i believe that
experiments are really useful for
knowledge building they're not just
useful
for doing av tests to optimize your site
there's a lot you can learn about your
users and your products
through running more sophisticated
experiments uh and that this plan out
system that we've developed supports
good experimentation practices
and focuses people on parameters and
makes it easy to do more complex things
rather than
baking off two alternatives
and if you use our system or adopt some
of the ideas from our system
it'll prevent you from shooting yourself
in the foot
and oh uh i should think
you can download it i guess hopefully a
lot of you have done that already
my collaborators on this project are
dean echols and michael bernstein
and i'd also like to thank a number of
engineers who worked on the
experimentation system
that a lot of the system is modeled off
of